.
- Tout bon scénario nécessiteune
Johnny Depp et Amber Heard : la
méchante était choisie d'avance.
L'acteur poursuit son ex-femme
en diffamation après qu'elle
eut écrit publiquement avoir ét.
Johnny Depp nie avoir été
violent et affirme que c'est
lui la victime. L'actrice
Le procès lève le voile sur
leur relation toxique, sur fond
d'abus d'alcool et de drogue.
ue les fans de Johnny
Depp lui témoignent un amour
incondit
sociaux ont explosé de haine
envers l'actrice.
BRIGITTE JOBIN, survivante de
violence conjugale- "J'en ai maa
gueule de menteuse." "C'est unee
grande malade." "Cette femme
est une vipère son venin engeree
des personnes qui lisent des
commentaires envers Mme Heard,
ça pourrait les décourager de,
- Pourquoi?
- Parce qu'on la rabaisse,
on la ridiculise, on en fait
vraiment, la risée, un peu,
de n'importe qui.orte qui.orte .
- Des stéréotypes que le
de chasser.LOUISE RIENDEAU, pp..
femmes victimes de violence
T'sais, on va s'attendre à
ce qu'une victime ait l'airait r
piteuse, à ce qu'une victime
collabore en tous points aveèmes
que ce n'est pas nécessairement
ça la réalité.
- Johnny
sa notoriété et aux appuis
qu'il a reçus.
communication
- Qu'on traite cettraite cettrae
comme un feuilleton, je trouve,
avec beaucoup moinité que d'auts
histoires "Metoo" qu'on conn
Je pense que, par exemple,
les victimes de Harvey Weinstein
de sympathie. Je pense que
les victimes de Bill Cosby ont
eu beaucoup plus de sympathie.
- Le manque de décrdre de vue lx
du processus judiciaire, sel
cette avocate.
VÉRONIQUE ROBERT, avocate de
- Le fait que la juge a l'air
d'avoir rien à dire, rien à
faire. Elle n'a pas de notes,
La posture, la nonchalance dans
la postut qu'il porte
des lunettes fumées, je n'ai pas
compris ça. Et der à la fin de
son témoignage, son avocate
venir le féliciter, mais en
lui faisant un câlin vraiment
choquant, presque perturbant.
C'est comme une amourette
naissante.
- Une anecdote digne d'un roman-
savon, dont les internautes se
régalent, friands d'une finale
procès-spectacle.- I have a feel
see eachother again.
Radio-Canada, Mon